russian troops are stepping up their
offensive in ukraine's industrial
heartland slowly but steadily seizing
ground with overwhelming firepower and
bloody tactics that are taking a heavy
toll on ukraine's defenders
as the conflict becomes a war of
attrition ukraine continues to call for
additional supplies of the heavy weapons
that could help it hold off the invaders
can and will europe and germany deliver
today we're asking russian offensive is
the tide turning in putin's favor
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to to the point it is
a pleasure to introduce our guests
beginning with lotta lundberg she's a
swedish author and journalist who writes
a regular column for the renowned
swedish daily svenska doug
and christoph von marshall is a
returning great guest great to have you
back he's diplomatic correspondent for
the berlin newspaper dertago spiegel
and joining us from bonn is my ukrainian
colleague roman gonzalenko who works
with dw's russian language service
and roman if i may i'd like to start
right away with a question about how you
assess the current situation in donbass
in fact russian forces are pressing
forward house by house village by
village
how bad are the losses they are
inflicting
well we what we are seeing now is um
probably the most difficult part of this
war um for the last hundred years of 100
days so since february when russia
openly attacked ukraine
um russia is gaining ground slowly but
it's gaining ground and it's because
russia changes tactics so it's now
pressing in one
um just um in one direction on a very
relatively small piece of land it's it's
a concentrated strike and um you have to
understand it's a it's it's a place
where ukraine had eight years to build
um its its lines to prepare for this war
that is why when the war started in
february russians were not moving at all
or moving very very slowly there so they
they had no success there now they have
some success and it could be a russian
momentum but still it's too early to
tell if the if if we will see a major
offensive and a fast moving forward of
russian forces in the coming weeks but
the situation is very extremely
dangerous i would say and how about are
the casualties
well we do not have um reliable
information about the casualties it was
unusual to hear the ukrainian president
vladimir zelensky talking about 50 to
100 um ukrainian soldiers being killed
every day um i think the actual figure
might be high on some days so it's a
very huge loss and you have to
understand ukraine uh doesn't have
as much as much military as um russia so
um the the the human um
the human dimension of this war um
is is very very dangerous for ukraine so
ukraine is losing its um best trained
soldiers
and um if there is no um quick help from
the west i mean um with weapons
deliveries heavy weapons uh anti-tank
weapons and all other weapons it will it
will be very difficult for ukraine to
hold that eastern ukrainian region
industrial heartland as you said and we
will come to weapons deliveries in just
a moment but let me go to lotta your uh
defense minister the swedish defense
minister spoke to our colleagues in dw
news yesterday and told them that the
russian invasion has changed the
security situation in europe as a whole
quite drastically would you agree with
that oh definitely that's why we have
sent in the application for membership
in nato
which was has made us schizophrenic in a
way because
three months ago they sell the same
minister of defense said i would never
over my dead body i would enter the nato
and now we've realized how dangerous it
must be because he changed his mind and
he's not the kind of guy who would just
kind of you know he's not a populist
this is dangerous and this had to go
very fast
and i want to come back a little bit
later to how public opinion sees that
but let me first
ask you uh christoph
foreign minister lavrov of russia has
called don bass absolutely key for
russia's strategic goals why is that
what is so important about this region
in the east and do you expect that its
fall could be imminent well
russians little bits changed their goals
for the war at the beginning it was um
they want to change the government in
kiev they wanted to occupy most of
ukraine they failed so now it's a new
definition what could also
constitute success or victory and
that is a certain change the donbass is
very important because you have the
russian-speaking
minority majority however you
you put it and um a part of the donbass
is already occupied since uh 2014. so
they just want to enlarge this uh this
piece of land and that makes it very
difficult for eu ukrainian forces
because the russians are now
concentrating on what they have on this
smaller region
and uh the ukrainians and that is a
little bit now the default of the west
as well this was predictable that it
would come to the situation that the
ukrainian forces which would need very
quickly more heavy weapon
they are on the way but if the west
would have started to deliver that
sooner they would be in a better
situation
i am not the big military strategist i
can only
tell you what i hear from military
strategists in germany and the u.s what
they are telling to me and the
optimistic picture is that they tied my
turn in the next two three weeks when
the heavy weapons which the west
delivers are in place and the ukrainian
soldiers are
trained on it
and so we would see a better situation
for the uk for ukraine in july or early
august but
the losses are very heavy and say first
they have to come over this period of
the next two three four weeks without
giving away too much ground because
that's the other side if the russians
get more ground and have the time to
establish more defense structures over
there then it will be very hard to get
that back it's easier if you keep the
situation flowing and then
ukraine might be successful in holding
um and also regaining territory and
we're going to take a look at the
defense effort in just a moment
two short remarks um i um slightly
disagree with russian aims i think that
the aim to replace the government to
change the ukrainian government and um
to
occupy as much of ukraine as possible is
still russian aim uh russia has just put
that aside and said okay we can wait uh
it's a war of attrition uh now and it
will be months uh and russia says we
have bigger resources we can do it and
the second thing is
the western weapons are coming that is
correct but russia is also attacking
ukrainian
trains delivering those weapons and we
do not know we don't have reliable
information how much is lost on the way
and is not coming where it should come i
mean in the east where the fighting is
now and this is also a problem because
uh ukrainian ukraine have has very
great great difficulties i would say in
delivering fast weapons it is a big huge
country it's it's a very long distance
and russia has a lot of time enough time
to attack roman just very briefly why is
donbass so important to russia is it
that famous land bridge uh the
connection to the crim
is it to crimea is it uh the gas
reserves uh that are in the eastern
region what what is it that makes this
their key focus at the moment
i don't i don't think that donbass is
more important than north where key of
the capital is or east where crimea is
and russia was worried about supplying
crimea with water from the ukrainian
river nipro so it is all important maybe
russia thought that in donbass
we can sell it as a victory better
because we've we've announced
at the beginning of the war that we will
liberate those territories and not
having success there was was kind of a
propaganda problem maybe this is the
reason or they thought if we strike
there
we do a concentrated strike and we um
move forward and uh then we'll it will
be easier for us to go further because
this is where most best trained
ukrainian troops are concentrated in the
east in donbas striking there and maybe
trying to encircle them this is what
russian aim is and then it will be
easier for them to move in other
directions now thank you very much now
let us take a look at those weapons
deliveries that have been mentioned
several times despite frequent pledges
of support for ukraine germany has faced
criticism both at home and abroad for
doing too little too late now chancellor
olaf schultz is promising to send
ukraine a modern air defense system but
will it get there in time
with heavy firepower and concentration
of its troops the russian army has
recently been making significant gains
in terrain in the donbass
ukraine has little to counter this
overwhelming superiority of 11 to 1 at
the moment
one reason the lack of heavy weapon
deliveries by germany and its allies
heavy weapons like the already promised
gapa tank or the haubitzer 2000 nowhere
to be seen
for its hesitant attitude the german
government is therefore being criticized
at home and abroad on a regular basis
that is not prudence that is hesitation
that is different that is timidity
a defensive mode from the german
chancellor in the bundestag he promises
more deliveries
in the coming weeks we will also deliver
more weapons
the german government has just decided
to supply the ukraine with the iris t
system the most advanced air defense
system germany has
germany has however already promised a
lot but is it enough and will it really
arrive
and let me put that question straight to
christoph and avid after that
announcement by chancellor schultz the
foreign minister angelina bairbach said
it could take some months for this
surface-to-air system to get to ukraine
yeah so germany is a little bit
acting
too little too late that i think that's
fair criticism one could also look at it
from a different perspective other big
european countries are not doing much
more take france or italy and they are
not on the spot germany is on the spot
because it is a country everybody is
looking to for leadership in in europe
and
so i think germany should be criticized
for it and also just announcing that
they will send additional things today
um that is certainly a reaction of
chancellor schultz he feels the
criticism has to react to it but the
real test is whether it arrives and when
it arrives so these questions are really
important i think there are two lines um
where schultz is moving but very slowly
because he's a very risk adverse
politician and what might be helpful
today might be wrong in three months
from now for the support of the
population so he makes two lines first
of all his parties the social democrats
are much more comfortable if they can
say well we deliver defensive weapons
not weapons for attack so for example
heavy tanks like the leopard as they
don't want to
deliver although it would help and the
second line generally is yes
ukraine should defend itself it should
not lose the war russia should not win
the war but there is this cautious
assessment but we shouldn't give ukraine
weapons with which they could attack
russian territory and that is something
president biden of the also i want to
come back to that in in just a moment
but let me ask lata to give us an
outside perspective because i know you
have been watching germany for uh for a
long time now and reporting on it so
in his historic speech on february 27th
right after this invasion began
chancellor schultz called it a turning
point and many people who heard that
speech felt that we were perhaps finally
seeing germany move into a readiness to
play a leadership role in europe in
common and security and foreign policy
but also beyond that to finally punch at
its weight as it were do you think it
has followed through is it walking the
talk no
i i
i think that the germans are identifying
with the projections that they have been
had at them since the second world war
and then we are really good at
identifying with being the bad guy
they really are tormenting themselves
with but you know with things that
happened 70 years ago and therefore
there is this talk about no more war
no more war on german grounds
nema aline sign and all of this and this
is this is holding the germans back
there is also a uh
i would say
rather
negativity towards the americans in in
germany and
you do or the germans do identify with
moscow
and spd is the social democrats are very
torn and even in sweden we can watch
this and see that he is he's not clear
and i mean he was now yesterday but it's
still not very german because the
germans should be acting on you know
what they say and they always have so
it was clear and yet two-thirds of the
speech uh were devoted to domestic
economic uh issues and social solidarity
uh which is why does he hesitate that's
the big question even in sweden we're
waiting for him let's
let's ask roman why he thinks uh
chancellor schultz uh hesitates because
you two have been observing german
politics and foreign policy for a long
time do you think this is his personal
leadership style that restrained
northern german
approach
or is it the legacy of the social
democratic party and those ties to
moscow and ospolitique that lotto just
mentioned
or is it perhaps
that he's uh been essentially
intimidated by putin's scare tactics
i think it's all of those things and i
would add one more i think it's also a
fear that um russia could cut off gas
supplies suddenly and german economy
would suffer
i think this is also something that he
has in mind when he's um hesitant
in
making a decision and deliver heavy
weapons to ukraine soon enough
so i think yes of course there is a
legacy of the his party the social
democrats there are there is a very
strong
pacifist movement in germany as a
country not just
[Music]
among people who vote for spd but among
other other um parts of the country so
there are very strong
ties to russia in eastern germany and
all those people are very skeptical
about weapons deliveries so the society
is split i would say and we have
and this is what polls are also showing
uh we have some 40 percent in favor of
uh delivering of happy with heavy
weapons and uh like 37 or 38 i think um
against it so this is something that
schultz also is considering
um and um but he will have to decide and
i think he's moving in that direction
but moving slowly
um
christoph do you think the chancellor is
right
to be
cautious to be fearful that a stronger
german a more proactive approach could
in fact precipitate uh world war iii as
he actually himself has said
personally in the military field i think
he's too cautious it's a different thing
with economy and sanctions
so i i would here give a split
answer from my point of view russians
are much more afraid of nato whether
it's conventional weapons whether it's
nuclear weapons then we should be afraid
of russian weapons in the long run
the west the eu plus the u.s
has an economic resources which are 15
times to 20 times as big as russia's
economic resources so if this is a war
of attrition if it lasts long then it's
from my point of view no question who
will win as long as there is
the political determination to support
ukraine as long as they want to fight
and give them what they need but germans
are afraid of this
nuclear thing and we just have to
to remind ourselves
we were at the front lines east germans
and west germans for almost half a
century and if there had happened a
nuclear war it would be on the territory
of germany and that
that has an influence and on our on our
thinking
where i think schultz is wise not to
push economic sanctions too far because
i think we all have to understand that
sanctions should be painful for the
enemy much more than to your own economy
otherwise you might lose over the
midterm range the support of your voters
and that is a real danger and i want to
take a look at sanctions in just a
moment but lotta
do you see similar divisions in public
opinion within sweden the economist
recently wrote about western attitudes
as a whole as this conflict becomes a
war of attrition and said it's seeing
the emergence of a peace camp on the one
hand and a justice camp on the other the
justice camp being those who say that
putin's breach of international law
cannot be permitted to stand would you
say there's a similar division of
attitude in your own country
absolutely yeah on the other hand sweden
always wants to be the best in the class
so now we've decided to join nato and
erdogan is kind of
stopping us
but that has just united us even more
before erdogan's talk about us letting
the terrorists walk the streets and you
know that he didn't put his veto into
this
it was more torn
while as now
we have gathered behind the idea that
we have to deliver sweden is one of the
largest
um deliberate country that delivers the
most the number one country per capita
who delivers the most weapons
and
yeah the discussion is there of course
bush
but you are moving ahead with nato
membership and that is a quite a big
turning point for sweden let me just go
back to roman very quickly if you would
roman the u.s is also now promising to
supply sophisticated uh surface uh to
air uh weapon systems
do you they also though have extracted a
pledge from the ukrainian government
that these will not be used to fire onto
west onto russian territory that was
actually mentioned by uh christoph
earlier
number one will that pledge do you think
be respected is it in fact requiring
ukraine to fight with one hand behind
its back and number two
will
this pledge be enough to placate russia
well i think um ukraine has is not
interested in in using those weapons uh
on the russian territory ukraine it was
very
um
or at least that was my impression uh
was very restrained in attacking russian
territory we do not have um reliable
information about that there were some
explosions in the board not far from the
border of
um oil um um refineries and things like
that but that was it so ukraine did not
attack um i think um territories like um
further deeper into russian state so
crimea was not really attacked and now
ukraine is not in a position even to
attack russian territory even with those
weapons that will be delivered next
those multiple rocket launchers they
only have a relatively short range or
medium range i would say and i do not
think ukraine has an interest and russia
has signaled very clear if ukraine does
that we will we we we have all options
on the table including nuclear so i
don't think ukraine will risk that
thank you very much let's take a very a
quick look at the issue of sanctions and
in fact the european union has now
agreed on its sixth package of sanctions
but getting to yes wasn't easy
oil pumped from russian fields is no
longer welcome in most parts of the eu
eu leaders in brussels reached an
unexpected breakthrough on the sixth
sanctions package just around midnight
on monday night
these sanctions are biting hard
and
are really
destroying and that's the the goal uh
the basis the financial basis of putin
leading this war and hitting hard the
russian economy
but the embargo only applies to oil
imports by ship a compromise to keep
hungary on board
the country will continue to receive
russian oil through the so-called drug
bar pipeline for the time being
the sanctions also exclude russia's
largest bank from swift bans three
further russian state broadcasters and
sanctions those responsible for war
crimes but how effective is this sixth
sanctions package
[Music]
let me put that question straight away
to christoph but coupled with the
observation that this uh exception for
the douchebag pipeline doesn't only
affect hungary also poland and germany
get oil via this pipeline so if they
were so serious about western unity
shouldn't they actually be foregoing
that oil now
yeah but they don't want to do that i
mean poland and germany made the deal
that they are preparing to phase out
over the next half year they want to get
there until january of next year and
just give the timeline in comparison
that we don't know how long the war
lasts so
hungary was not the only guy or the only
country in the room which would have
problems with an oil embargo just right
now also bulgaria the czech republic and
so on and so on but we should blame
hungary for not being willing to find a
compromise to play only on its own
interests and here i think the eu has to
think about to which degree
the importance we give to unity isn't
overrated i think in this case we should
sometimes tell countries you know we can
do consensus minus one then it's a
strong signal of 26 countries and every
time the issue is mentioned hungary
would be blamed for not trying to
to join the eu so more political
pressure by eu minus one might be a good
tool yes and in fact there are calls to
drop maturity at a consensus voting but
uh that would be a whole show in itself
so we won't go there uh lotta when you
look at uh the state of this much wanted
western unity are you concerned that it
could shatter going forward
i didn't get the question now what
shattered the western unity this united
front that the west has celebrated and
uh rightfully so uh in the beginning of
the war well that's definitely one of
putin's goals
you know that we that we implode or that
we depart from one another so we just
have to be aware that that must never
happen
because the war against ukraine is not a
war just against the ukraine it's a war
against
western values it's an imperialistic war
and if we don't get that
we we we are in serious trouble
let me take us all back to the title uh
of this program and uh we asked
essentially whether the tide is turning
in poutine's favor roman how do you see
it
oh we're not hearing you it's a sure
go ahead uh the tide could be turning
for putting could be turning for putting
but it is short-term perspective in the
median term and in the long term i think
putin will lose definitely
christoph
same feeling that i think the tide is
just for the moment turning but not in
the long run the west will win if they
are committed to support ukraine
we have to deliver we have to deliver
now
thank you
thank you to all of you very much for
being with us and thank you also to our
audience for tuning in see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
you